well welcome to all of you I'm Rick
McCallum vice president for research
here at carnegie mellon it's a great
pleasure to have all of you come today
it's a wonderful turnout we're really
appreciative that the Secretary has
taken the opportunity to visit Carnegie
Mellon we really look forward to
continuing the dialogues that we heard
from President Obama in his State of the
Union speech about innovation and
building jobs in America and really the
critical challenge of new energy and
manufacturing and here at Carnegie
Mellon were very dedicated to working in
this area thanks to all of you for
coming to the gates center this is a
great building and this is really an
innovation engine the Hillman center for
future technologies is here and every
day our students and faculty and staff
are creating new innovation here that
lead to new jobs through our startup
companies Carnegie Mellon creats ten
companies year based on this license
technologies that come out of the
university 20 if you count our student
companies per year that's a lot of jobs
we're trying to do our part here in the
United States we can't do it alone
Pittsburgh is really really important to
all of us and all of our economic
development partners and all of our
investors here in the region so we have
a really rich ecosystem here in this
area and we like to think of ourselves
as a model for the rest of the country
we maybe we can't be sort of maybe
Silicon Valley or or Boston but we we
think of ourselves as the model for
maybe the rest of the country they're
trying to rebuild we have a vision here
called green lighting startups where we
really try to work the faculty and
students and staff together in a way
we're all helping each other not only
here at the University but here in
western Pennsylvania and so this is
again from a university point of view we
look at this as as a great model we have
a really valuable partnership with
Department of Commerce they've led the
program called I six which is these
innovations zones and we were very
fortunate with the innovation works to
win one of the
to create this agile ecosystem and 31
companies have come through this program
and are really trying to through this
program create these companies in a very
fast way in an agile way to create jobs
as fast as possible so my own company
here has been involved in generating
these sort of jobs and we along with
companies like aqueon are expanding our
manufacturing in western Pennsylvania so
trying to do we can to help to bring
back manufacturing to United States this
is really a really important moment in
the history of the United States as we
try to rebuild our economy we believe
through innovation the innovation
economy and the vibrancy of our young
students and faculty that we can play a
major role and partnerships like high
six are really important as the
government takes a leadership role so
thank you so much for visiting it's a
great it's a great pleasure to introduce
to you our mayor and our partner Luke
Ravenstahl he's created a program called
power up Pittsburgh where they've been
leading the charge in our innovation
ecosystem here in Pittsburgh for helping
to product space and leadership and it's
great to have an energetic mayor who
really takes charge on this issue and is
really supporting with that I thank you
so much for for visiting
thank you very much Rick and good
morning everybody it's a great to be
back at Carnegie Mellon University again
I want to thank Rick for his kind
remarks I also want to take a moment to
thank dr. Cohen who I understand is
abroad at the moment for his a
partnership in power at Pittsburgh and
all of his efforts I know Tim McNulty's
in the house somewhere where's Tim at I
always like to embarrass him maybe he's
out and on the hallway working which Tim
does best as many of you know for for
their work i also want to introduce and
recognize County Executive rich
Fitzgerald who's here today in the front
row my new partner in government here in
southwestern Pennsylvania thank you rich
for being here and look forward to his
work and our work together and
continuing the great things that have
happened in Pittsburgh as many of you
are very much familiar with this region
has undergone a tremendous amount of
transformation over the last 20 or 30
years from a region that was
predominantly focused on steel to a
region as we all know through the
leadership of Carnegie Mellon University
and many of the other fine institutions
is much more diversified but we still do
here in southwestern Pennsylvania and
just saw an example of it this morning
at a qui on as we still do make things
maybe not as much steel as we used to
but we're still proud of our roots in
history in manufacturing and that's
really what today in many ways is about
I had the chance to be with the
secretary this morning in lawrenceville
to talk about some of the things that
are happening here in Pittsburgh and
some of the things that we as a country
need to focus on from getting back to
training as we talked about this morning
it's amazing the lack of qualified
trained manufacturers that are out there
to do the jobs that are necessary here
we talked about this crazy idea that we
bring the best and brightest from around
the world to places like Pittsburgh two
institutions like Carnegie Mellon
University we spend all kind of money to
bring them here and then we educate them
and then the first thing we do is we
tell them you know what now you have to
go back to your country it's crazy it
needs the change President Obama
understands that
the secretary clearly understands that
and we're happy that they're here in
Pittsburgh to highlight this to talk
about it and to look at us really as a
partner in that in that effort so we're
happy that you're here mr. secretary
it's my honor to introduce secretary
Bryson he's the 37th Secretary of
Commerce he's charged with implementing
President Obama's ambitious agenda to
strengthen the economic recovery and to
accelerate job creation secretary Bryson
understands the issues facing American
companies after nearly three decades of
business experience including 18 years
as the chairman and chief executive
officer of Edison International the
secretary serves as a voice for the
business community in the president's
cabinet and has said his top priority
and this is great news for all of us is
to carry out the president's plan for
economic recovery including putting
renewed emphasis on promoting exports
and improving American innovation and
competitiveness so let's give a warm
welcome a warm Pittsburgh welcome to the
Secretary of Commerce John Bryson the
sector
so good morning and it is a great great
pleasure to return to Pittsburgh I've
come to Pittsburgh many times over the
last 20 years for various reasons and I
love being here and I love what I find
here at what all of you are doing in
building the economy here taking these
steps forward we care a lot about steel
in this country we have challenges with
regard to still and some things that
I've been working on with regard to
protecting our steel industry in some
ways some of the international trade
issues around the world but what's also
being done and what the emphasis today
is on the startup and early stage and
more advanced energy companies and
that's the world that I've worked in for
a long time that's what we did at Edison
International so I really absolutely
delighted so a special thanks to you
vice president McCulloh thank you for
your leadership in the research area
thank you for your own creation of these
companies and taking them further and
mayor what you've done here is truly
extrusion taken Pittsburgh from a
position in which economically is in
dire straits
and with discipline and creativity and
persuasiveness putting pittsburgh in
this position great strength economy
and which because I'm so focused on it
all the time in the country on putting
pittsburgh into a position where the
unemployment levels are really down in
ways not it's not true in so many places
in the country the adverse effects of
that for our economy and for our young
people and particularly their
opportunities but people of all ways are
so dire thank you for that special
leadership thank you so I want to thank
also your Dean of energy producer who I
know has been such a factor and I had
the pleasure of meeting and talking with
him this morning I know he's here with
us let me tell you just now going fairly
quickly through what I've done this
morning and I've been doing it places
around the country and at the time of
the presidents presidents addressed to
all of us it's particularly inspiring
the things that he set out that really
are the things that will significantly
lead and govern what I'm trying to do
and hopefully doing
I will tell you that taking this
secretary position on was nothing that
had ever come to my mind I was off doing
other things do I doing the things that
I was doing and all of a sudden I got
this phone call and that's what's this
about they talk to my wife bad kid so
I'm very excited to have this
opportunity so what we've done this
morning is I met initially with the
district export Council quite a number
of you are here this morning these are
people who work significantly in their
careers in export and volunteer to work
in connection with the Department of
Commerce on advancing us so these are
people that know it Noah from ground up
from their own businesses the steps
they've taken in various way so special
thanks to them then I toured aqueon and
we'll go through that further this
morning's God is here a company to grow
out of Carnegie Mellon I won't say much
more about that but is perhaps those you
know and we'll get into this further
they do really strikingly cutting-edge
work with advanced batteries with kind
of potential and by the way the kind of
talent and drive that startup companies
with a vision with an opportunity to do
something really great brain that's
something that I was doing quite a lot
of my dividend fertilization my career
but the last three years I've been close
to these kinds of companies and they
make a difference in our country one of
our special traits as Americans that
really is in contrast to substantially
all the advanced
economy countries elsewhere in the world
is the extent of which we are
entrepreneurs we are set up people we
break the norm and find ways to get to
new place new technology with new things
to be done and that is a special quality
of leadership all right so
let me talk a little about what the
president is focused on now we need our
US businesses
to build it here
but to take it and sell it everyone
that's just a constant refrain for us
here in western Pennsylvania you're
creating companies that are built to
last and you're creating good jobs with
them to nationwide we added 3.2 million
private sector jobs over the last 22
months that's a striking number but it's
not nearly what all we need to get done
last year however that figure we added
the most since 2005 so that's a step in
the right direction and we just have to
keep charging honest pittsburgh has
dropped from over nine percent
unemployment perhaps all you know this
but I'm struck with it too less than
seven percent at the end of last year so
below the national norm significantly
today we need to build on that momentum
and it starts with manufactured
president recently asked me to co-lead
the White House Office on manufacturing
policy on doing that today over 11
million Americans have manufacturing
jobs over the last two years
manufacturing has added more than
330,000 American jobs that is the
biggest jump since the nineteen night
so that leads to just touch on my top
priorities they are touched on these or
what as well my top priorities you take
on a job like mine across a large Bureau
and unless you prioritize and prioritize
ruthlessly because the mayor would
concur in that you have to be very
focused and I am focused on advanced
manufacturing and exporting and on
encouraging and developing more
investment here in the US so let me
touch on each of those first the
Department of Commerce created a
national office for the advanced
manufacturing partnership that's at NIST
we were talking a little about it
earlier today our work there on this
national office base which by the way is
for the benefit of the entire federal
government universities and business so
of bringing it all together and our
workers are really focused on so this is
an exciting thing ruston to be asked to
take line and it's part of this
leadership the president asked me to to
provide in the advanced manufacturing
area at this facility we are supporting
cutting-edge fields like IT biotech
nanotechnology if you go to NIST and say
for example
my nano technology center it's just
stunning to see it's just incredible
aunt something unique about this is this
is for businesses to come to and test
and tweak in advance work with their
products so this is not like here does
this help but can you hear me alright so
the idea is to address key problems such
as the fact that too many advanced
manufacturing jobs are going unfilled
it's a core problem we've got we're a
country of immigrants
but now we're saying to these most
talented people that come here at
Carnegie Mellon from all around the
world and you don't have a place to
continue to stay after you're here for
now and that is really wrong we every
place I talk on this subject people
stand up and say we need these
incredibly talented people that made our
way and I know that's the feeling here
all right so that's that let me turn to
my second priority and that's increasing
US exports we are focused on doubling US
exports by the end of 2014 some of you
may recall that in the state of the
union two years ago the president set
this goal out double US exports exports
mean jobs business opportunities great
thing to do there was a lot of
skepticism at the outset and
understandably could you possibly double
in five years
and the answer certainly isn't done but
in the last two years in the Commerce
Department is the agency that federal
our government on that is direct to lead
this we do it
and we're very proud of the fact that in
these two years we've actually slightly
exceeded the pace that we need to be on
to double by the end of 2014 now what I
want to underscore for you and it's
every time I talk for people for
commerce department I say this the fact
that we've done well so far as a long
ways from getting the job done and so
you take it the look at the economy and
particularly the credit financial
position now that you see in Europe
which has been a great area in which
we've exported challenged that will have
some x impact on exports on the other
hand we have these new free trade
agreements particular Korea and Colombia
that present opportunities but it's
going to have to be high intensity all
the time achieving that doubling of
exports how do we do that I'll touch on
a very few things are commercial offices
of commercial offices of the comments
operate in 80 countries they are
recruiting foreign buyers to make
connections with American firms the
administration is also working to reduce
trade barriers and strengthen the
enforcement of trade rules you heard the
president say in the State of the Union
speech that now in office is being
created in the White House that further
backs up the enforcement of the trade
rules the administration is also working
to reduce anomic cover that when
American businesses compete on a level
playing field American businesses
almost always when when the loving when
the field is leveled we bring the energy
to creativity education the talent we
win II for this panel I thought you
might find it interesting because the
focus is energy that right now we are
sending trade missions out focused on
energy just to be done but the next
within the next few weeks 12 Saudi
Arabia and the second to Brazil both are
focused on clean energy and on energy
efficiency so that's another way we
reach out and seek to build this
export base and expanded so then third
let me turn to the priority more
investment in the u.s. we've recently
rolled out a new initiative it's called
select USA we're training our commercial
service officers in over 100 US cities
to help increase investment here and we
want to build on what's called in
sourcing so in sourcing is the trend
we're beginning to see businesses that
have gone abroad set up their facilities
abroad China would be a common place
where they've gone massive market and
they're beginning to come back to the
United States
and the reason they're beginning to come
back to the United States we had the
president hosted about two weeks ago an
in sourcing meeting there were about 20
CEOs of companies from large like Ford
Motor Company too many small start-up or
early stage companies but what they work
including what we think will be a trend
that will go further and we will work
hard to encourage you is when you're in
the US you have the opportunity for
supply chains for talent for working in
ways where the markets are and working
in ways in which though our wage levels
are higher than elsewhere in the world
our productivity is much higher and
elsewhere and the rest of the world and
in places let's just take China as a
notable case their wages have gone up
very significantly four times in the
last decade and the kind of the quality
of products not invariably but in many
cases turned out are not at the level of
quality that people in the US are
seeking both to have but also from the
US base to export elsewhere so in
sourcing is something to watch closely
we're working hard on it we think it has
great potential and then what else we
need to foster economy that further
fosters are further supports
entrepreneurship innovation and
competitiveness
so we need to build an economy in which
there are many more young people
inspired to pursue STEM education
training degrees at places like Carnegie
Miller only thirteen percent of our
graduates across the u.s. are getting
stem degrees our countries like Korea
like Germany elsewhere are around 25
percent so in other words these
countries that are formidable economic
competitors
are so disciplined in the quality and
the kind of training they're providing
that goes to this question of why do we
have the unfilled jobs and they don't
and we've got to deal with that so that
needs to change so we need more support
for federal funded research beyond that
as President Obama said in his State of
the Union we can't gut investments in
areas like basic research if we do that
again we will let other countries win
the race for the future and then finally
we need to make sure that the most
innovative goodbye ideas are being
commercialized so one example of that is
just a year ago our economic development
administration again a part of the
Department of Commerce awarded six
million dollar is in grants to foster
innovation for the leadership of
Carnegie Mellon and innovation works and
we'll get to that Pittsburgh got one of
these I six grants highly competitive
it was a real commendation to all of you
hear that one of the grants was awarded
here in October you held I'm told a demo
day was startups with this program one
firm called match com of energy
efficiency was the focus another firm is
focused filling a niche helping small
business networks together among
themselves and break into foreign
markets all this stuff is exciting so I
would say it is clear that we out my
case in the federal government those of
you in the private sector can work
together to help businesses start grow
and succeed doing that we can help
achieve our national priorities while
creating jobs that are so so intensely
needed you
our country's face competitors around
the world all those competitors face the
troubled global economy that we face and
none of the others are backing down at
all we can't back down either we need to
create a very clear and competitive
strategy and a long-term strategy not
just a few months
a short term of long term
the disciplined strategy for growth
that's what the others are doing that's
what policy Greta bleah we haven't
some level we assume that our wonderful
economy put us in a position to world
and lead the world forever and that
isn't the case so my commitment to you
today is that we will continue at the
Commerce Department across the federal
government to provide energetic tireless
and effective support to help not only
these wonderful businesses and people
here in western Pennsylvania but across
the entire country both compete
and when thank you very much
now how should we do this just a
terrific please tell everybody we're
going to transition and then you'll be
in charge so at this point we're going
to have a discussion with our panel
members and we led by the secretary and
then at the end we'll open it up for
questions from the audience good thank
you so what I want to do is simply put
questions to you and rich I thought
maybe a good place to start if you
wouldn't lie
to describe what you led to the wind and
the i6 competition take us further into
that sure so I'm rich lunette president
CEO with innovation works we're a
southwestern Pennsylvania led venture
development organization that for
20-plus years has provided early stage
investment and business expertise for
many of our region's highest growth tech
firms we've actually worked with Plex
tronic star and and aqueon by providing
investment and or grants and assistance
and they're great examples of how the
region's innovation system are creating
new jobs entrepreneurs face a lot of
challenges in getting these companies
off the ground and over the long term I
think the US economy's ability to create
the next Intel Google Microsoft is going
to have a primary reason we're going to
be successful in my experience these
companies need a lot of help getting off
the ground they need access to risk
capital than a world-class talent and
they also need great innovative
breakthrough ideas one source of those
ideas are our nation's universities and
federal lab systems you know federally
we spend on the order of about 150
billion dollars unfed erally funded
research and here locally we've seen the
fruit of that particularly from places
like Carnegie Mellon University creating
so many large employers and
manufacturers here locally but commonly
it when this basic research is done in a
university environment there's a great
gap between basic research the product
of very thick research and commercial
endeavours and if you're a researcher
studying advanced materials and you
think you've you've you've got the money
from the federal government and you
think you've stumbled on a commercial
entity oftentimes you can't use those
federal funds to take the next logical
step in commercialization which might be
market research building a benchtop
prototype test
working with mentors or advisors looking
at the IP landscape and so with the help
of CMU we've created something called
the I six agile innovation system we're
partnering with see tech the don jones
school of business project olympus
quality of life center and many groups
here within carnegie mellon university
trying to surround these teams with
micro grants to do these buildings bench
cal prototype tests engage early and
often with customers and figure out how
to target these products for market we
have currently incorporated more than 60
mentors and advisors so these are former
tech CEOs that have walked in the shoes
of entrepreneurs that are able to advise
and help them get these companies off of
ground we're providing space and other
critical resources for these companies
and a net programs bearing fruit and
it's important to note that in a place
like Carnegie Mellon University we've
already started at a point that's far
better than most universities across the
country CMU has one of the very best
records in the nation in terms of
commercializing research in fact if the
rest of the company country operated
like CMU you would see three to four
fold increase in the number of
university based spinouts but the
support through the Obama administration
is critical to helping us leverage the
tremendous research at asset here
locally and to create a national best
practice that we hope can be replicated
other places and I should note that the
Department of Commerce has been a
particularly strong supporter of
innovation works we we currently have
two other grants through the Department
of Commerce the jobs and innovation
accelerator challenge that the mayor's
team and others have been great partners
on and currently a grant through the
economic development administration so
thank you for your support well let's
that's what we're here to do and
Carnegie Mellon and all of you here are
a great reason to provide the support
right here so we like that a lot all
right let me turn then
to Scott and to Lalit and maybe later
I'll ask you to go first well I'm a
lolly tortilla i'm the CEO and founder
of Power Technologies so I'm glad to be
here at CMU because this is where I
started I came here to do my PhD program
and in my second year I started my first
company Super X as as I was being my
doctorate program and actually I cannot
agree color I couldn't stay longer but I
wanted to make sure I got you in this
morning so so we started the first
company in our thinking of it saying how
do I start the company and there was a
sba rd on april fifteenth and so in 14th
night we decided to write one so we
wrote it all night and submitted it and
we got funded and since we got funded we
started the first company so soon vs it
was nineteen eighty-two long time ago so
we started the company and we got the VC
funding and this is the time when
pittsburgh was going through his crisis
and there was hardly any VC funding over
here we are one of the few companies to
got in it and we raised about 12 million
dollars created about 50 jobs over here
and then I left super excited the
company from scratch and we built up the
company to about 150 people 20 million
dollars in sales and we are created all
the jobs here we manufactured here in
western Pennsylvania and sold all over
the world whether it's be China or India
or Brazil we produced in western
Pennsylvania and sold it and a couple
years ago pretty much in the fourth
quarter of super bowl we signed a
contract to solve that division of the
company so that got sold that day and
steelers won that day so that work out
it's a good day it has good
so out of that they said you know we got
to do something we got this very
interesting technology called
supercritical fluids which is you know
user co2 which you and I breathe in and
breathe out so it's considered organic
physiologically compatible zero
pollution no air no water no solid
pollution and we decided to focus on the
energy side so last year we spun out the
new company called her energy and the
first thing that we focus on this
geothermal and when I say geothermal I'm
not talking parts in generation I'm
talking ground source heat pumps the
reason we are interested in that is if
you look at all the energy in the u.s.
thirty percent of our energy goes to
heat and cool these buildings that's a
lot of energy and it takes a lot of
infrastructure to deliver this energy so
what best you can do is if you can
reduce this energy consumption even five
percent it will have a significant
effect not only you become more
efficient but all the billions of
dollars that you have to spend to bring
additional energies are the
infrastructures the grid lines and the
pipelines if you can reduce that that
will have a significant effect on the
society so that's our concept and we use
co2 instead of using free on which you
know co2 has zero global warming
potential zero ozone depletion potential
it's a great fluid it's inexpensive it's
available everywhere so we're using that
directly to go into the ground take the
heat in the winter from the ground and
put it into the building and vice versa
and the summer where we take the heat
from the building so that's what we are
doing we have grown to from zero last
year beginning of last year 29 and we
expect to double this year and hopefully
our plans are to double every year for
the next five years and the best part of
it we expect to produce it here in
western Pennsylvania and sell it all
over the world not only the United
States we see big markets in Middle East
and India and all and China so we are
excited being an energy company being a
manufacturing company doing all of this
out of southwestern Pennsylvania so we
are doing that and we are doing that by
building a building and our IDC park and
converting that into completely
geothermal so that's of a demonstration
site so we'll see how it goes so you're
excited about the future thank you
now let me give this for morning I'm
going to ask you in the audience and you
across the panel to follow up with our
panelists and dig a little further into
what they're doing or whatever might
intrigue you to learn more about their
businesses but Scott Scott came just a
year ago to be the CEO of acne on he has
been part of taking forward startup
companies for a much longer period of
time he came here but to western
Pennsylvania from Boston my recalling
that correctly and so this is something
that I was able with my team to go
through and see this morning it's
extraordinary early stage but really
promising battery enterprise and Scott
why don't you take that for it okay
thank you so aqueon energy for those of
you that don't know about us we make an
advanced battery system and it's
designed specifically for large-scale
energy storage applications those can be
making the grid more efficient by
addressing the mismatch between supply
and demand on an hourly in a daily basis
and it can also be used to make
renewables both wind and solar primarily
more consistent as you know when goes up
and down during the day solar goes up
and down and those don't our batteries
can it can make those act like base load
which is a constant so you tuck the wind
away when you have extra and you release
it when the wind isn't blowing so lots
of applications for our batteries
everywhere from small five kilowatt hour
batteries about this size all the way up
to city block size batteries for
utilities a very big potential market
for what we do the technology was
created at Carnegie Mellon Professor J
Whittaker who was still a professor here
he splits his time between us and
Carnegie Mellon we fight kind of emo and
all the time for J haha a very talented
guy very very very unique solution that
was really custom designed for these
applications he really set out and said
how do I address these long-duration
hi cycle harsh environment applications
and also be extremely inexpensive and he
found a material set from available
precursors and green precursors that all
made that happen together so that is now
proven that is now in prototype product
that we've shipped outside customers in
the fourth quarter and we are in the
middle of taking that prototype product
and simply scaling it up into a
production quality building block that's
happening now that should be done by q2
2012 at that point we continue to build
that into low volume product for the
rest of 2012 and 2013 is a very exciting
year for us we will turn on our
large-scale manufacturing facility and
really ramp that company up to hundreds
of millions in revenue pretty quickly
when you think about the potential of
those those applications and frankly the
simplicity and the cost point to what we
have we're really excited about it so we
are in Pittsburgh today we're in
Lawrenceville we have about 70 employees
we had 20 employees in February we're
coming up very quickly we will have 200
employees by the end of 2012 and on the
order of six hundred to a thousand
employees in three or four years so
we're really coming up primarily at the
plant level as I said that you look at
these look at our early stage companies
and I don't say we're a start-up anymore
i think we're an early stage company
where we are actually we have shipped
product we are going to ship a lot more
product and the technology risk in the
business risk is manageable so really
for all for us it's right now it's about
execution it's about finalizing that
design scaling up manufacturing selling
it and then scaling it from there so
it's pretty exciting times i'll echo the
Secretary's comments about talent I'm
from Boston and that Boston is a
one of the hubs in terms of Engineering
and Technology and we have trouble
finding talent a specific engineering
talent manufacturing talent here we also
have trouble finding in Boston we have
trouble finding it in Silicon Valley
it's not just a Pittsburgh problem so
that's something we will waive bull wave
that flag every time we can get it now I
agree that the insourcing phenomenon is
happening i think the pendulums one hard
one way and I think it's gradually
coming back the combination of higher
costs overseas but also the IP control
that's something we're very concerned
about its making sure that our IP
doesn't get leaked out and especially by
contract manufacturing if we can control
the factory it's easier on that the
other thing I want to just spend a
minute on is the challenges of a startup
company we've been extremely fortunate
most startups aren't as fortunate as we
have been so far we at the beginning had
CMU sponsorship so Jays lab and Jays
work was funded in part by CMU a good
infrastructure there we kleiner perkins
one of the premier venture capital firms
found us early and injected about a
million dollars in seed money into the
company which was great the do we not
the loan guarantee program much more on
the it was part of the Recovery Act put
in five million to the company alongside
the VC money and that really got us to
the point where we could demonstrate a
technology that works then we were in a
position to hit the VC market again
kleiner perkins came in again for
somewhere just just south of 10 million
dollars and last year we were fortunate
enough to be able to raise another 30 so
we are starting to cross what everyone
refers to at least in the DoD is the
valley of death which is you've invented
it but you've got to get to this
commercial product up here and it takes
time and it takes a lot of money in our
case I haven't said this publicly but I
think it's interesting is we are we have
been authorized by our board to invest
100 million dollars in this company in
two years and that number keeps growing
as we really roll this thing out so as I
said we've been fortunate I've been in
other startup companies that have not
been so forth and it we bootstrapped it
and made it work what the reason I think
we've gone so quickly we came out of CMU
in 2009 so we've very quick
and I think that's a testament to the
funding we've been able to get at the
support we've been able to secure and
frankly the partners we've been able to
work with from the venture capitalists
to the innovation works to the to just
Pittsburgh etc so it's been a really
nice ride and the future looks very
bright for us right now again it's that
execution word that were really focused
on now and that takes talent so will be
will be you know any good talent send
them our way okay thank you so this
stuff extraordinary promising companies
now let me turn quickly to the vice
president McCulloh so he joins Carnegie
Mellon to lead the research area but he
himself is an entrepreneur and has built
businesses and you want to comment on
those thank you very much John secretary
so yes I'm very fortunate to be here at
Carnegie Mellon because this is a great
place to be a professor and to think
about starting a company in 2002 we
started a company called Flextronics
that company is a material Vance
materials company that makes inks that
are printed to create the next
generation of electronics so the next
television that all of you will want is
called OLED television and it will be
made and manufactured in a few years and
we look forward to you buying that so
it's a sandwich structure that is about
this thin the television itself will be
about this then it has mainly four
layers two electrodes and two layers
that light up their light emitting
diodes we make if you one plastic
creates the light and the other plastic
allows it to live for a long time and
have very bright lights we call that the
cheese we'd like to say we own the best
cheese in the world so we're hoping for
that to all take off we've created a
over there's 70 full time employees here
in Pittsburgh 80 if you content if you
count our contract contractors we're
expected to grow
we've sort of flattened out with the
economy but now we're getting ready to
to grow again we've brought not only
great jobs and kept talent in western
Pennsylvania but we've actually
recruited town to the area we're also
working with us manufacturers to do the
next generation of light lighting which
will be a printed white light that you
can put anywhere and all these things
are extremely energy efficient and and
use very little energy and will replace
most of the lighting that you see so
very large manufacturers like GE for
example or in this game and and trying
to lead so we're very very happy to be
in that business we have a lesson they
say is we have a joke we like to say and
this is a joke at the the greatest
investor in the world is not in New York
but is in Nebraska and the greatest
software company is not in Silicon
Valley but it's in red bytes in
Washington written Washington and the
greatest print electronics company in
the world is not Germany or Japan or
Korea but is in Pittsburgh but thank you
very much for giving me the opportunity
to talk about that well you know this is
really striking to come to Pittsburgh
and Carnegie Mellon and have this flower
this flourishing of ideas and people
that are drawn together to create these
wonderful new businesses and that will
make a difference for all of us and it's
it's a really tough thing to start to
the startup and in all of you and David
they're always very hard times this is
something I've done a lot of
particularly in the last three years but
I work with a lot and it engaged a lot
of thing I most wanted to do part of the
time the president called me and people
that do this you know they sweat they
work really hard they the people would
do it succeed go through the inevitable
challenges unforeseen problems and they
work them through and they come to a
conclusion and they know when they're
starting up this kind of business and
you don't see people willing to do this
so much elsewhere around the world they
know that the rate of success is far
from extremely hot in the end we are
taking a risk you're willing to take the
risk and you know the carnegie mellon i
would think one of them the most
exciting things beyond what we're seeing
here today is that you're setting a
standard for your students and the
people that are come here the people
that come in engineering and sciences
but in many fields and saying all right
so la lead came here and while he was a
student started his first company and
today's students must be looking at that
saying something similar night where I
live and I would having to live in
pasadena california so I've been in
California for a long time
and it's everywhere there it's
everywhere I live right by Caltech
extremely talented people and there is a
new sense at a place like Caltech that
has always been of course an
extraordinary research university
remains that but a growing number of the
students want to do just exactly this
and that's not been true so much ten
years ago all right so let me turn to
all of you and tell me what time we have
10 minutes left so I want all of you in
the audience to put questions to our
panelists and I was told that I should
do the same and you know that you're
also invited if you want to ask the
question of me I'd be delighted to do
that but I think the stars are the
people that are actually doing it so I
recommend that the questions go to the
panelists but don't hesitate if you'd
like to ask me a question about anything
that I do I'd be delighted to respond so
yes
your comments by saying compete and win
yes and beyond the programs and grants
and contracts incentive incentive prizes
have had quite a roll yeah enterprise so
lindbergh landed in Paris for his 25,000
bucks Carnegie Mellon and IBM defeated a
grand chess master using a computer for
a threat comprise 4,000 bucks hundred
thousand bucks and google has a quarter
225 million on the street right now for
a non-federal mud landing through your
White House you have a
fifty-million-dollar prize authority a
vector to NASA coincidentally but you
got the authority and it's never
committed the money sits and I'd have us
all just a dream about what a
fifty-million-dollar incentive prize
might do for whatever these interests
are and since we
intend to land that Google prize all
right it wouldn't trouble us if you but
maybe 25 million down one on the booth I
got it started out there are a lot of
I'm sure there are a lot of good things
that might be done with it that's other
than just sitting in the till so I can't
I can't tell you because I just don't
know about the 59 but on your point
about incentives to give a little
special boost level of support real
recognition to people that take these
kinds of initiatives that you know since
I'm working in the advanced
manufacturing area and I'm working here
with the economic development
administration in the Commerce
Department you know we are very focused
on incentives so let's just take one of
the things that the president set out in
the state of the union speech and that
is his proposal they deeply believes in
this and I certainly do as well for
having more favorable tax treatment for
manufacturing and advanced manufacturing
and having more favorable tax treatment
for those that put their facilities and
their operations here in the US relative
to taking them overseas so specifically
what he said is that with regard to
taxation those that move their
facilities and their jobs out of the US
should be contributing in the US some
level of Taxation beyond what they
otherwise would because they're simply
taking it away and of course some of
them they're taking it to places around
the world where taxation levels are a
kind of Haven and really that that is
undermining so much of what we need to
do with our economy and
people and with regard to manufacturing
at advanced manufacturing it you know
manufacturing is the home of much the
largest part of innovation that occurs
in the business side of our innovation
in the country so something like 60-some
percent of the innovation that is
occurring in private sector businesses
is in the manufacturing sector so we do
want to incentivize and reward that and
reward that further the i6 grant was
that's what it was all about and it was
a highly highly competitive undertaking
and so for this team and Carnegie Mellon
to win that that was absolutely a grant
and a highly incentivized grant that's
the kind of thing we do I actually know
NASA fairly well because I've done on
the board at Caltech and very close to
JPL this period of time but I just don't
know the specific answer to your
question there I wish you great success
with it yeah yeah yes
we've also been engaged with the u.s.
eggs in bed and not can everybody here
we've also been engaged closely with the
US Exim Bank and I also noted that
President Obama recently made the SBA a
cabinet-level position yes so could you
expand on what are the initiatives
around Exim Bank and exporting that
would be new as well as what's going to
change with respect to the SBA yes and
we able to hear that changes with regard
to the small business administration and
the Exim Bank so let's start with Exim
Bank the Exim Bank is a critical part of
our federal government infrastructure
for providing financing tax Porter's
large as in the case of Boeing which is
you know we are so fortunate as a
country to have Boeing and have Boeing
do all the Assembly of all its planes
here in the United States that's not
inevitable that that should happen to be
the case and so export support for
selling what is our biggest export
product in the country the boeing
commercial airplanes XM is a big part of
that what we need honestly is we have so
many opportunities now to do this
financing and maybe you've seen the XM
Bank is running short of funds so the
president and all of us are very focused
on seeking to persuade the Congress to
appropriate some additional funding and
I think there's a reasonable prospect
that that will happen now all of us are
I think everybody across the country
isn't some level discouraged by the fact
that at this Congress there is so little
agreement things just don't get done
that ought to be done that's so
important we hope that will be done
with regard to the Small Business
Administration there are some additional
initiatives there as you perhaps know
they have offices all over the United
States they reach out and provide
financing to small businesses the name
implies what I'll say there is there
some initial steps that are about to be
taken that we think will offer
additional support yes last question yes
the back of the room a large number of
unfilled positions and relative for the
high skilled positions I think you had a
but what can be done to train
people for the lower skilled positions
in to increase the work ethic so people
apply for position
the boy wants to hire
I mean it's critical that happened and I
you know shame on us for assuming that
just taking the view that young people
ought to go to college is sufficient in
targeting the kind of training that
makes sense so the Germans have led the
way significantly is perhaps you know in
basically taking great pride and
families whose children have a great
interest in assembling and putting
things together and building things and
don't choose to do this as part of being
a academic university setting in which
it's done the Germans have done it
terrifically and I think we've in some
ways misled young people in the extent
to which we've just emphasize going to a
university and getting a liberal arts
education and we're so short of the kind
of training we need at the Commerce
Department of what I've been doing is
reaching out a lot with the Department
of Education where I really think the
leadership is strong and we want to use
our ties to businesses because
businesses are very ready to support
stronger education they do it in many
ways and then finally a lot of us are
very focused on the community colleges
where across the country those community
colleges are the institutions that to
the greatest degree have the students
and can train them with more focused
programs than is elsewhere in the major
universities in the country so those are
steps that are being taken with a big
big emphasis
so well I thank you very very much